hello everyone alana here another very
exciting day for me because i have
received a box also this is my foster
dog
she's very sweet but she panics whenever
i am not immediately
in her eye line
um because she's been at a shelter for
so long that she's just not had any love
so she really stares at me a lot
sometimes if i move my hand away she
gets upset
see
oh i'm sorry i stopped petting you
how rude of me in any case we got a box
from techland
you excited about the teclan books it
says dying light 2 stay human which of
course is a game that just came out and
i am really enjoying it i'm enjoying it
a lot i feel like i'm in agreement with
the reviews that said the story is not
very good but i still like a lot of the
characters but yeah i have no idea
what's in this uh they did tell me they
were sending me something i just have no
clue what it is which is my favorite
kind of unboxing this is not for you
so let's open it shall we
[Music]
oh it's the galaxy's edition
which i am positive that i have seen
before but i still don't remember what's
in it
i have absolutely no doubt that i have
seen this in one of their presentations
but i don't remember so this is a pc
collector's edition
for dying light two no spoilers you guys
can look at this i'm just not gonna look
at it wow cool whatever is in that wow
who knows let me move the camera down
slightly
so you could see the dog just as much as
so you could see the unboxing also
nobody look at my cables hide my shame
okay i'm gonna take off this nice sleeve
and this one
that's kind of cool it says
finders keepers and there's a little
hand down the bottom here and some kind
of letter
okay here it is this sets once we'd
cooled off after the release of dying
light 2 when we all got together and
spoke seriously for the first time about
making a sequel we were of one mind the
safe more of the same in a better
package option absolutely would not
satisfy us
if we were going to make a second dying
light it would have to crush the first
in every way it would need to set new
standards not only for post-apocalyptic
style games but for all open world games
period this was the birth of our
unquestionably most ambitious project
ever i'm gonna be honest with you
working on a game especially one as huge
and complicated as dying light too can
be a very frustrating and thankless task
that is true this is in large part due
to the fact that production of a big
budget title drags on for years and
doesn't bear any tangible fruit for a
very long time we only find out whether
we're going in the right direction at a
late stage of development when all the
different elements come together as a
whole and if all went well the vision
comes to life until that moment we have
to survive on faith but neither that
faith nor the incredibly talented team
we were lucky enough to gather under our
roof would have been enough without you
me with aura and gratitude we have
watched a community of gamers
spontaneously form and grow around dying
like tomb the kind of community every
company in the business dreams of it has
been this connection to the wonderful
people who came to love our game that
has driven us over the last few years it
is what made us keep pushing the limits
of our abilities and fight through every
moment of doubt that's how much we
wanted to repay you for the trust and
patience you've given us techland isn't
just us it's you two if we were to let
you down we'd be letting ourselves down
as well thank you for being with us and
helping us create a game we are proud of
and that is signed by the chief creative
officer adrian
that's super nice thank you my friend
we have
a steel book is what this looks like
nice steel book let's open it up oh
that's creepy my gosh the back end of
that damn
here we
go creepy
very creepy and this side is a zombie
cool effect
i imagine it doesn't have a game in it
ah okay yeah just a steel book with a
code
um which i
will give away let me let me get uh i'll
think about that think about what i want
to do and i'll give it away to one of
you at the end of the video so you can
play the game on pc this looks like a
map to me
this actually feels really nice it's
like a really nice textured map here we
go
very cool
it's obviously just one of our first
areas
oh this is villadore so this is the
first area i tried to mock as many
useful places as i could it's getting
tougher each day anyone who finds this
map use it and continue the night run
its job
this is actually super interesting hey
you can't have that no i know you want
to be a part of the unboxing but you
can't have that she has a um an eating
condition basically like a disorder
where if she eats anything other than
her exact medicated food it will be
really bad for her she could die so she
can't have any snacks she certainly
can't chew on cardboard and it
definitely is a challenge with a large
doll i wonder if this will um
have like helpful
information for stuff that i'm not aware
of
because there are x's on the map but
maybe there'd be things that i could
already find i don't know
interesting yeah it's a really nice map
though it feels really nice which is
cool
it's gonna have extra stuff on the map
isn't it
the batteries in this
so this doesn't appear to be working but
my guess maybe there'll be batteries in
there somewhere
my guess is that
the map probably has some um
like black light
things on it which is cool okay it is
time
to lift this up oh that's heavier than i
expected oh oh okay okay all right
let's
cut
the tape
i love an outlook always love an art
book
that's what we have on the top this is
the art of dying light too
okay plastic is off
the art of dying light
to i do feel like they did a really good
job with the world design it doesn't
look like just like another generic
apocalypse game
architecture buildings tell stories
these speak of a vast wealthy european
city whose spectacular growth was
abruptly cut short by the plague
well yeah some of this is gorgeous
just really nice environment on
very pretty give me the zombies i want
to see the zombies oh i love this one
that looks like the paraglide area
it's like i'm showing you a picture book
because i kind of am
that's creepy
very cool i love a notebook i always
keep them okay and then we have not sure
what this is some lithographs probably
little prints yeah
there's the windmill supposedly that
mission structure is very different
based on what choice you make which is
neat
oh that's upside down
very nice
i think that's it yeah so we got some
prints these also feel really nice it's
like a nice texture a lot of this just
feels nice is there a thing only i
notice i don't know
oh cute we got some stickers here
very nice
look
it's you
you like
it
she tried to eat it
zombie
well that's cool i like that one it's an
interesting design
um
very cool so those are a bunch of
i'm assuming stickers unless they're
like fake tattoos which is possible
yeah stickers
okay and now we have a statue
dying light to collect edition statue
uses manual let's try and figure it out
first so that's going to be in the lower
half of this box it's really light so
i'm guessing this is plastic
rather than like a polystone or a resin
it's already uh completely assembled
which is neat this is smaller than i was
expecting
it smells so plasticky they always do i
always check the paint on these i'm like
very critical of
the paint jobs it's pretty good there's
some nice detail
a lot of texture work
i love a cool pose and the pose is
definitely cool oh it also takes
batteries
oh that's neat oh this stuff lights up
that's very cool i don't have a
screwdriver for that right now
unfortunately
but how so i guess
this would light up and potentially also
this little light right here which is
probably your uv lights because that's
obviously such a big theme of the game
oh is that the
the light switch is this little great
that's so cool
i love that it's a really cool design
yeah i'm sorry i don't have the um
ability to show it to you guys lit up
right now
um i'll post something maybe on the
community page or something when i when
i get it um lit up that's neat
nice dynamic
statue for sure
very cool
um and that's everything a huge thank
you to techland for sending this over
this is a very cool collector's edition
it's like generally the stuff i want to
see i always want an art book um i love
a statue and yes i suppose i also
have a pc code to give away if you can
tell me in the comments
give me your favorite zombie movie ever
and why tell me what is your favorite
zombie movie and why
keep it less than 100 words and i will
pick the answer that i find to be the
most
unusual and it will reach out to you and
give you a code it's pc of course so
it'll be steam
and it is probably only going to work in
north america unfortunately
you also have to give me a means of
contacting you so you'll need to leave
probably your instagram or twitter a
place that you have dms open so i can
actually reach you
and give you the code thank you all for
watching
i will see you guys next time bye